hey guys i'm ryan right hi brandy price
yep she's learning how to say her name
alright it's Richie come on commie off
guard that's okay you hear that I could
do something hey you see if I get my
back oh that was pretty good I did mine
earlier I'm not even double joining
that's not even like weird attractive
that's like holy [ __ ] something's going
wrong note we're gonna watch the trailer
for Jupiter ascending the third trailer
it is the creators of potentially my
favorite movie of all time The Matrix
the witch house keys they're not the
witch house key brothers anymore because
one of them is a woman now and it sounds
weird to go to witch house key brother
and sister that run yeah away from you
exhausted though [ __ ] Adam I am like
trying to catch breath right now
I don't know how I did Tough Mudder so
me either 11 miles and he's like huffing
and puffing after forces maybe he's out
more the psychological angst I'm just
gonna say that because that's a great
point actually it might be something I
smoked earlier too so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna watch this trailer
Jupiter ascending
the Wachowski they're awesome I'm all
for transgender rights if you change
your sex star Channing Tatum and Mila
Kunis Oh both who have earned respect
over the years I agree
we've been taught that the birthplace of
the human race is earth
do you know what this will do people
when they find out the truth
I don't think that most people would
want to know the truth
your planet was seeded by abrasax
industries roughly 100,000 years ago
it's one of the most powerful dynasties
in the universe there are three primary
heirs the oldest is balem is the one
that controls this planet and once you
get
you're royalty you are the one
the exact same genes reappear in the
exact same order
we encourage
yes his life is going to change if she
wants it I'm surfacing
I never I don't
once you can to you
tomorrow have you ever seen our harvest
never but I've heard they feel no pain
I'm not exactly sure over watching but
show me the truth about love you want
well
you must I have more in common with the
dog that I have with you
okay truth be told I get the basic
concept of the story it's something
about the acting and the way it looks
like it'll play out it just doesn't seem
like the story itself is gonna be
anything truly that great but I feel
like it a lot of it will be great set up
pieces for great visuals and great
action pieces yeah which is I'm sure
that's what most people are gonna go for
are you well absolutely I was just
seeing a podcast with them with them
about this movie I'm making of it and
this is the first trailer that I've seen
after hearing the podcast and they're
all ridiculously intelligent yeah and
and it's all this existential idea ilysm
that they want to put into these movies
and they want to make films that people
don't necessarily get and that's okay
yeah I mean I agree I'm really thinking
it's just the trailer because they make
complicated [ __ ] films yeah like they
did in the Matrix which no one could
[ __ ] pitch so they just said what is
the matrix and it seemed to work well
they just did Cloud Atlas which was
definitely not for everybody did you see
that I did I liked it
I did too I thought it was really good I
really enjoyed it
I was I'll be honest the first hour I
wasn't enjoying it but for some reason
the last like two became an incredible
to me the first part of it you're like
turning into this it's hard to follow at
first yet but then your brain acclimates
to the pacing structure in the structure
and what actually is going on and then
you start formulating your own opinions
yeah so it works and that's the thing
that I'm hoping this movie can do too is
like something that really does get your
brain think of those but amplified the
sci-fi role of The Matrix it's like they
brought action to a new level
they brought style tuned level and they
brought like a philosophical crazy
mind-bending story to a new level
well I think what the coolest thing
about what they did is with well
starting with a matrix of course was
bringing that not only Humanity of it
but into an action film but also like
the thought you know like you're
bringing your mind into into it as
opposed to just being like no offense to
Michael Bay or anything like that but
like into a Michael Bay film because
there's no there's no really light I
wonder how Michael Bay would feel about
that brandy well he knows that he's not
making films to provoke thought he's
making films to make money yeah provoke
the entertainment side yeah I thank me
kind of boring alone no I mean it I'm
saying I have loved a lot of his movies
yeah the trailer seems like he's trying
to simplify it but the one thing I'm
still having a hard time getting on
board with because I just want this
movie to be like a movie they truly just
wanted to make if that if that's that
but I know it's gonna be better than
this dream
okay cool cuz if they were on a podcast
I know they never new interviews yeah if
they're on a podcast and promoting this
film that's a huge deal because that
shows they probably like this a lot you
know even if not everyone will get it
I'd love to go for something complicated
but I'm still going why did they cast
Mila Kunis in Channing Tatum like I
can't really see them in those roles
granted just a trailer but still it's
like Mila Kunis yeah I don't think they
sold the love story really in the
trailer they didn't sell they didn't
sell the love story between the two of
them
was no like you didn't see any
established chemistry or anything like
that between the two of them was just
like hey oh I love dogs
yeah and like Channing Tatum's character
they don't even really establish yeah
yeah he's just like a rejecter
genetically dissimilar to her because
she's royalty of some sort
I love Channing Tatum like I think you I
think he's great but I'm still watching
the trailer but I'm watching the trailer
and I'm still like why did they just
hire a real British to do the role
instead of getting Channing Tatum it
just looks weird in the makeup to me
like I'm having a hard time separating
them my mind from that is Channing Tatum
in weird makeup but that could be
changed when you watched it yeah the
execution could really change it all but
yeah I'm more than confidence probably
just a trailer that's making me have
these concerns I'm concerned if you guys
are new to the channel you get subscribe
yeah and check out Brando so check out
Fanny's bracelet all right check out
Brandis Facebook you made it work
facebook.com slash Brandie price not
actor night Sean hey Ryan man you get a
shout out all right keep up the funny
[ __ ] it's amazing night Sean you sound
like something that is a demonic type of
worship what night so what do you think
I like like a dark color lip balm oh um
no yeah you know what it's other demonic
worship or lip balm you guys decide
hmm one panda man he said about Sally
sorry but his salamander salad stupid if
she is I'm stupid as well and we would
be so perfect together
throw me a shoutout tank you okay one
Panda man that's a horrible hybrid to be
I don't think I'd be attractive at all
one Panda well you could be
makes black and white and they make some
pretty babies
oh just saying dude you just got the
chocolate of vanilla going nah yeah in
case you guys don't know we're we're
talking about we're seeing these half
black half white I just said that you
didn't make that clear did you say black
and white you weren't listening I
thought I was yeah I might have been
preparing to say that in my head yeah I
wasn't listening but I know it was like
raising your hand to talk but he was
raising his hand without the action of
it he's like can I say no can I say it I
want to can I say it now okay black and
white hello hi your voice is always
going speaking a dog
t-dog 100 Brian can a request for a
shout-out for August 2015
I love the channel and watched all the
time I don't get what that [ __ ] means
requested shoutout for August 2015 so he
wants a shout-out in August 2015
dude I go an order of requests I'm not
gonna wait that long what if I'm not
around there's a kilo tonight she could
murder me tonight I do carry a pocket
knife I do carry a pocket up around here
dude t-dog 100 why don't you want to
shout now what's wrong I I think we
should shout now alright I don't know if
I like the name tdawg no no I'm sorry I
like you he's probably black as well
what's tdawg no I just reminded me of
teabag like jokes huh this one over here
I'm sure you're lovely and yeah I'm
sorry
yeah it's quit teabagging people you
[ __ ] yeah unless they're really into
it elisee does it with 100
nailed it nailed it
that's not we're just meeting space
explosions d tdawg i think you've got
him the best shout out of all time
congratulations
keep teabagging